so today we're gonna talk about the
consequences of a fatty liver that you
may not associate with a fatty liver
let's go through them some you will some
you won't when you have a fetid liver
your inflammatory markers go up not just
in your liver but through the entire
body the problem with that is will
increase a condition called insulin
resistance okay so then that that's
going to increase more insulin so
insulin is going to create this problem
but then this problem will create more
insulin through creating this condition
called insulin resistance if the
inflammation is there too long
chronic inflammation the liver you start
developing scar tissue of the liver
it's called cirrhosis this is where you
start having some really big problems
most liver problems are asymptomatic you
don't have any symptoms for a long
period of time until you start losing
the actual function of the liver cells
but you'd have to lose a significant
portion of your liver for certain things
to show up like a site ease where you
have this fluid in the gut that might
not show up until like 90 percent of
your liver is destroyed but the problem
is that this can be brewing in the oven
without you even knowing it a real good
way to know if you have a liver problem
is just look down and see if you have a
gut if you do that means you have a lot
of spillover or fat or visceral fat
that's spilling over from the liver
because the liver is already filling up
with fat that fat then causes
inflammation and eventual scar tissue so
the point is that you want to understand
what's happening so you can change a
couple things in your diet so you can
actually actually reverse it because you
can if you get it in time number three
when you lose the function of the liver
you lose the capacity of making bile
because the liver cells parasites make
bile and bile is necessary to dissolve
and absorb the fat soluble vitamins and
a lot of times people don't connect the
dots between a lack of bile coming from
the liver and their vision for example
because they have a vitamin A deficiency
or their lower mood because they have a
vitamin D deficiency or they might have
flaky skin
or they might have really sore muscles
after exercise that just won't heal
because they're low in vitamin E and
vitamin E can also can't cause heart
problems and angina or they might have
little broken blood vessels from but
lacking vitamin K and that all can come
from this right here so when they
consume those vitamins it doesn't really
work because they don't have the the
bile to help resolve it and pull it into
the body so they also are not absorbing
omega-3 fatty acids so this will show up
in inflammation so they're taking the
fish oil but they still have a key
joints they still have pain in the body
also they might not connect the dots
with a thyroid being well because it
takes a bio and a healthy liver to
convert t4 to t3 the active form of
thyroid hormones so they might notice
their metabolism is slow things are
sluggish they lost that vitality what
happens when you lose the capacity of
the liver you increase more toxins
because you can't eliminate the toxins
with the help of bile you also start
holding on to more estrogen one of the
functions of the liver is to help get
rid of excessive estrogen and cortisol
so if you're holding more estrogen you
can start developing really soft skin
and lose your body hair just from this
alone this is why right here because the
liver is losing function or increasing
cortisol and you're always stressed out
and number four a fatty liver will
decrease testosterone so some people
take the biochemical hormones but the
real problem is coming from the liver
number five they start developing
metabolic syndrome might be pre-diabetic
or diabetic high blood pressure high
cholesterol and their focus on the heart
not the liver the liver is the cause the
heart is the affect belly fat that's the
number one indicator for a fatty liver
and heart disease as I mentioned over
here so there's three big things that
cause a feather liver and one is called
de novo lipid Genesis this basically is
the conversion of carbs into fat in your
body so when you do a high carb diet
okay you start generating on a fad that
starts depositing in your liver I put a
link down below for more information
about this but people with a fatty liver
need to be on a low carbohydrate diet
also the fructose high fructose corn
syrup the corn syrup will create a fatty
liver faster than any type of sugar
alcohol will do it as well now there are
two nutrients that are essential for a
fatty liver one is choline because
choline helps dissolve fat especially on
your liver and by the way egg yolks have
choline and vitamin E but don't get the
synthetic version get a natural version
a complex that has half to cough rolls
and half tocotrienols okay very very
important this has been known to
significantly reduce inflammation in the
liver as well as in the arteries and
also decrease the formation of scar
tissue which eventually turns into
cirrhosis but don't even think about
taking these two unless you first get
your diet corrected the diet I'm going
to recommend is the healthy version of
ketosis and in a minute fasting together
as one I put a link down below if you're
new to my channel so and then I would
recommend taking these two and this will
help you start reversing this right here
alright thanks for watching
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it